MIT and was an undergrad student doing
research with a calendar and let's talk
about books on meta complexity I think
and he'll tell us more about the
cryptographic approach to harness
all right so thank you Valentin and
thank you all for coming
uh so this is I'm going to be talking
about joint work with uh Huang who's a
undergraduate student at chingwell I
think he's applying to graduate programs
now so I don't know if those decisions
have been made already but if they
haven't been made you know
great great researcher and this is also
a joint work with online Wren who you
have probably met or should meet if you
have not
and um you know
it's a real privilege to be giving this
talk uh
on Eric allender day uh Eric is someone
who's been very important to me
um I was when I was at Rutgers he was
really my undergraduate advisor
and I so when I Was preparing for this
talk I decided to go back through my
emails and figure out you know when was
the first time I actually interacted
with Eric
and so I I opened up Gmail and I I put
in like from colon Eric allender
and this is a screenshot you probably
can't tell but you know there's this
little search thing that comes up it
says 1 to 50 of many
and uh you know there's so many great
emails from Eric but finally I came back
and I searched and I you know I found
you know what was the first email I
actually uh
got from Eric it was some bureaucratic
thing
uh you know I spared you the details of
the bureaucracy it says hello Rahul uh
sorry it took me until today to reply to
you
and I was like I you know I looked at
the email I was like okay that's
interesting you know Eric I don't know
how well you guys know Eric But Eric is
extremely prompt at responding to emails
and I was like okay you know like what
is well how long did it take Eric to
reply to this email and so I looked at
the previous message and it was the
previous day
yeah barely been 24 hours
and Eric was apologizing to me
um about doing this and I think you know
this is a nice anecdote about Eric
um so let me tell you a little bit about
how I met Erica and the role he played
in
my kind of
introduction to this field you know
so in junior year of college I by chance
uh signed up for Eric's class one of my
friends had told me hey this class is
kind of interesting uh maybe you should
take it and I had a slot in my schedule
and I said okay you know why not uh
didn't think very much of it
and to say truly the very least
uh uh Eric's class had an impact on me
and uh I still remember my my favorite
lecture of Eric's was
one where and I don't think I've ever
seen in any of the classes that I've
taken uh Professor Moore enthusiastic
and with more uh passion for the subject
than when Eric you know got up he stood
up and he was he's telling telling how
alternating time and space are dual
Notions you know with alternation time
and space are dual motions and it was
just it was just this exciting uh place
to be where you know like I was learning
about the subject and uh it was just
really wonderful and so
at the end of the class
you know I really like the subject
and so you know I worked up the courage
and I said you know Eric hey
could we like uh do a research project
together or something is there something
to work on and I remember Eric
didn't like hesitate you know and he was
just like uh later that day
I got an email uh a list of papers about
some strange
object called the minimum circuit
science problem you know which obviously
even today is like you know pretty much
all all I work on
every once in a while I
venture outside of it
um
and I think looking back
at this time
uh
working with Eric
it's truly remarkable how generous he
was with this time
in particular you know like I would uh
you know often just go knock on his door
at the Hill Center and be like hey Eric
do you have a few minutes
and you know usually I would spend like
the next hour uh pestering him with
questions and you know half-baked ideas
really not even half baked they're
mostly quarter baked uh and I think I
mean of course I appreciate it at the
time but like now you know seeing how
busy it is you know to be a researcher
especially to be a professor I think
what's really amazing is that whenever I
you know when I knocked on his door and
I asked him do you have a few minutes
he
you know said yes
every single time
you know which is is just in in Crazy
like um actually I'm lying there was one
time he said no do you remember no no he
was uh there was final exam scores were
due that day and I think I think he
actually sent me an email afterwards but
uh and that's another thing like his
emails it's like is with this one
exception actually uh you know you'd
send him an email and the responses
would be the same every time it'd be
detailed it would be in line and uh it
would be usually within an hour uh from
when you sent your email
and
you know uh
I don't I really don't think that like
this was like an exceptional thing for
Eric
I think this was the dedication he had
uh towards all the students and I think
particularly towards younger maybe
undergraduates who uh
uh didn't you know we're new to the
field I think you know year after year
Eric takes undergraduate students in
this dymax reu program which I somehow
found my t-shirt from it says Eric
allender on the back somewhere there's a
puzzle if you want to solve it
um and so year after year he takes these
undergraduate students and um in my
estimation
few people
in the field uh
have done as much as Eric has and giving
opportunities for undergraduates to uh
do research and complexity Theory
especially undergraduates who otherwise
would not have had the chance
and so in short I'm very grateful to
Eric and I want to say Eric thank you so
much
thank you
okay so
now we're all here uh there's this
question you know that Eric sent yeah
was talking about in in that first
reveal that he sent me which was related
to the NP hardness of meta complexity
and so you know this is a
very important question uh whether
certain meta complexity problems or MCS
are and be complete and there's a whole
meta-complexity zoo of problems like
combat and komagora complexity
conditional versions uh whatever this is
a long-standing open question
and one thing that's interesting that
has happened over uh has really been
developed especially with Lewin pass
in recent years
is this connection or ideal hope for
connection between the NP hardness of
meta complexity and cryptography
so in particular you know there's this
Holy Grail idea
that if you could show the NP hardness
of meta complexity
maybe that gives you a way for basing
let's say one-way functions on uh P
versus NP you know somehow these uh NP
complete NP hardness and meta complexity
might be related uh
to these fundamental problems in
cryptography and so this is something
we've heard a little bit about uh you
know Rahul talked about it in the
original the first talk Karen if you've
been around for the workshop this is
something that's mentioned a lot and um
I want to say you know we have this
perspective
uh NP hardness might help cryptography
but ask not
what NP hardness can do for meta
complexity or sorry and medical
complexity could do for cryptography
let's ask uh what cryptography can do
for the Envy hardness of meta complexity
and uh this might this might seem a
little strange at first uh
but actually there are already some
works
that do this I think maybe they haven't
been discussed so much yet uh there's
this one great example but we have heard
about maybe a little bit uh shuichi and
this breakthrough work
uh last year showed that this problem
mcsp star which is so close to mcsp is
NP hard
and that was using information theoretic
cryptography it's using this idea of
secret sharing it's using this idea of
one-time encryption schemes these are
really cryptographic Notions although
they're in the information theoretic
setting in this talk that's not what
we're going to be talking about we're
not talking about I'm not not asking
about the information theodic setting I
want to ask
can computational
cryptographic assumptions tell us
anything about the NP hard discipmatic
complex
and in some sense the results that I
alluded to earlier on the slide do say
something about this you know this seems
like a kind of strange thing because
usually when you have cryptography it
tells you that problems are intractable
it doesn't say that they're NP hard you
know you have a one-way function you
have an encryption scheme it's hard to
break the encryption scheme it might not
be NP hard to you know like breaking the
encryption scheme doesn't mean sap is
solvable you know it just means there's
some assumption that's broken
but uh let me give you an example of
some some of the results that are known
along these lines
and uh
so the first
scenario I think you can kind of say and
this is basically implicit in cabinets
inside
uh and maybe you know once you see the
proof this theorem is not going to seem
so interesting uh but but there is
something maybe maybe there that you can
take away yeah what's the most General
notion of NP completeness that you could
possibly care about it would be
something like this mcsp is NP if and
only if uh NP is in p
you know that's like it's you know it
may be a bad notion of Envy completeness
because then things that are really
doesn't don't like any problem that's
not in P would be NP complete
um in in the real world that we think
but okay here's like a very simple proof
of this if one of my functions exist and
you have this like extremely uh this
implicational NP completeness
well if one of your elections exists
then p is not equal to NP and uh mcsp is
not not
which is you know I I'm not going to
tell you how to do that but that's
something that you can do and so like uh
you know in such sense cryptography is
showing
that this is like implicationally NP
complete but it's not not clear what the
takeaway is and it from this really it
seems more like this is saying if if
cryptography exists then both these
problems are intractable you know like
it's not really saying that uh you have
some sort of np-completeness
relationship between the two and
then another result uh by Russell
Valentin and Ilia vokovic which says if
indistinguishability obfuscation exists
then well I'm not going to explain to
you what that is but that's some
high-powered really nice cryptographic
object then you get mcsps and zpp if and
only if NP is in CPP again some sort of
implicational version of NP completeness
but again the the takeaway is a little
murky because like uh you know what is
this really saying
it's it's a bit unclear so I you know I
don't wanna I'm not gonna give you the
proof of this because I need to Define
indistinguishability obfuscation you
know that uh it's a 45 minute talk and I
spent a few minutes talking about Eric
but uh
what I want to ask is we could ask let's
start ask a different question instead
of asking if computational cryptography
can help us prove like these
implicational NP hardness what if we ask
about the standard definition of NP
hardness you know 10 cryptography prove
that you help us prove the usual Black
Box notion of NP completeness that is
like uh can cryptography tell you if you
have an oracle for one problem you have
like a Oracle for another problem you
know and this seems like a kind of weird
question seems like maybe this uh
when you first look at this this might
seem a little strange so cryptography is
proving some sort of Black Box
np-hardness result oh is it clear to
clear what I'm saying when I say black
box is anybody confused
I just mean like the usual EPL Oracle
for one unit Oracle for another like
many one reductions okay
and so what I want to convince you in
this talk is that in some cases the
answer to this is actually yes and in
fact it's not as strange as you might
think
okay so this is this is my goal for this
talk this is what I want you to take
away besides the fact that Eric allender
is a wonderful and amazing person
um okay so let me let me tell you a
little bit about this maybe make things
more concrete I'm going to tell you
about two cryptographic objects in fact
actually I'm not even going to tell you
what they are yet I'm just going to tell
you what their name
uh so the first one is this thing called
witness encryption uh yeah I'm gonna
give you a definition of witness
encryption
later but for now basically all you need
to know is that it lets you somehow get
a lock box uh using some formula you
have some sat formula fee and you can
lock things up and the lock is basically
the set formula fee I'll explain it
later and there are some results uh
about Windows encryption in fact it was
it was proposed in this paper by uh Garg
Gentry so high of waters and uh they
proposed this construction that you know
if you look at it it shows that it
exists in some ideal model and then
recently using this work of of Jane Lynn
and sahai you can show that witness
encryption exists under well-founded
assumptions so this is just some
cryptographic thing these are kind of
really standard I mean okay I'm not a
cryptographer but my understanding is
that these are standard uh things that
are known in cryptography
okay and then there's this other app uh
object snargs uh I've I've put an i here
because snogs are somehow corresponding
to short Witnesses
um and there's some uh really
one of the foundational results here is
that this they exist
in some random Oracle world so here are
two cryptographic objects if you're a
cryptographer these are things you are
very familiar with
and it turns out you just squint at
these three results
and you turn your head
and really
you know guard Gentry sahine Waters Jane
linen say hi Silvio Macaulay what they
did
is they showed that actually some meta
complexity problem corresponding to the
cryptographic object is Black Box and BR
and this is this is what I'm going to
tell you about and in fact the
reductions aren't are like almost
syntactic it's a it's kind of crazy uh
and so at least in these cases you have
this cryptographic object and the NP
hardness of meta complexity are two
sides of the same coin
okay
so let me tell you about one of these
results
let's start
and um
The Meta complexity problems that we're
going to be talking about NP hardness
for are these conditional meta
complexity
oh are there any questions so far
either I am very uh done a great job
explaining or I've lost you all
completely
um so one is this version of conditional
circuit complexity
and uh so CC's here stands for circuit
complexity and you could ask you know
what's the circuit complexity
of computing one function given access
to another function
so you have some it really X and Y here
are truth tables of some function you
can ask you know if I have dates
that compute one function how hard is it
to compute gates from another function
so this is some conditional complexity
measure
does it make sense
okay and then another uh conditional
complexity measure you could have is
conditional time-bounded complexity
which now you know instead of talking
about circuits you talk about programs
that run in time T they're given a
random access uh RAM access to Y okay
two conditional
uh meta complexity problems
and so we we knew uh for this first
problem that it's NP hard up to like
roughly a log and factor and then uh
Lumen pass uh showed that this is also
NP hard to a login factor and actually
showed that uh on the uniform
distribution
this problem is like equivalent to
one-way functions but that's not the
focus of this talk so I'm not going to
go into it so much and then it was later
improved to this end to the one over log
log n Factor by hirohar and this was
based on some information theoretic
cryptographic ideas
and one kind of
aspect of this result whereas if you
look at all these proofs they all work
in the regime uh
where the time bound is in some sense
sublinear like you have this conditional
string y but your circuit is so small it
never can it can't access all the bits
of Y and uh your ran you you have Ram
access to I but again you can't access
uh all the all the bits applies
I don't know speaker response oh did I
see this backward oh yes yes yes sorry
sorry this is this is wrong it should be
the time is much much less than uh the
length of the fly
and you might think okay well you know
this is just some aspect of the proofs
this is what we know how to prove maybe
why yeah whatever we've solved the
problem let's move on
um
but kind of interestingly hirahara
showed that actually this this question
like sublinear regime versus super
linear regime is actually really
interesting
in particular
um if you could show conditional time
batted chromagor of complexity in the
super linear regime is NP hard then
heuristica which is uh this world where
sat is hardened
uh hard in the worst case but easy on
average that didn't make sense you can
ask that man over there he defined it
um
then hirsuka doesn't exist so this is so
somehow this distinction between linear
uh super linear and sublinear seems to
be very important okay this is that's
the background on what we previously
knew about these meta complexity
problems and now let me tell you
how this object which is witness
encryption implies some interesting
things about these conditional problems
so
the so the first theorem we show is that
if sub-exponentially secure witness
encryption exists which is uh something
if you're a cryptographer this means
something to you if you're not a
cryptographer this is something we
believe on computational assumptions
based on well-founded computational
assumptions that's all that matters then
actually it's Black Box NP hard
to distinguish the case where the
time-bounded Commodore the conditional
time batted komogorf complexity is like
some small polynomial in N versus almost
maximal like constant away from maximal
and The crucial part here
is that now
we're in the super linear time regime so
previously like the yes and the no cases
you know you couldn't let yourself read
all of Y but it turns out if this uh
cryptographic object exists then you get
pretty much ideal uh
hardness of approximation you can't
actually hope for hardness of
approximation lower than this
um under like NP hardness otherwise you
get like a sub exponential time
algorithm for SAT but if you modify the
Assumption slightly you could get so
this is this kind of shows that sub
exponentially secure witness encryption
uh implies black box and be hardness of
this problem and in fact uh oh yeah
emphasize this already and in fact what
this shows is that under plausible
cryptographic assumptions the problem
that shuichi shows
uh it's NP hardness would eliminate
heuristica is MP hard
so in fact you know like it's kind of
this interesting State of Affairs we
know the reduction
you know you believe these cryptographic
conjectures we actually already have the
reduction that shows that this thing is
NP complete and that if that thing is
then be complete then we eliminate
heuristica
um but of course you have to be careful
about this because like all right we're
assuming sub exponentially the strong
cryptographic object in if you assume
that cryptographic object then
heuristica doesn't exist anyway so you
know like uh oh yeah I already have a
question say you know the reduction the
reduction
yeah actually that's a good question I
don't know if there's like a universal
witness encryption thing but you you can
take the construction
um that Jane went into hide yeah and
then plug it in you know probably it
works
there's Universal IO which implies okay
yeah yeah so I guess there is
yeah then it would be although like I
guess and you were saying this the other
day maybe it seems like witness
encryption might be a significantly
weaker object like yeah
okay that's okay so this is a result you
know it's cool now we know I would say
okay I at least now I think I know that
the ground truth is that this problem is
Black Box and be part
but uh at least for the purpose of
you know eliminating heuristic it's not
clear what this means and and you might
be like okay how interesting is this we
have some conditional result it would be
really nice if you can get something
unconditional but that sounds really
difficult because uh you know like if
you're using a cryptographic assumption
it seems like you'd only be able to
prove MP hardness
assuming that cryptographic assumption
what's surprising is
you can actually use
this ideal like uh This original
Construction in the paper that proposed
witness encryption they have this like
uh construction that says well if things
were ideally like something
uh
then this witness encryption exists and
you can use that to unconditionally show
uh some NP hardness per circuit
complexity and this this kind of uh is
gives the best known hardness of
approximation for for this problem
and uh one thing and I'm going to
mention okay actually let me mention
that later so this is what this is the
description of the two two theorems is
are there any questions
you know that's a great question
um
so sorry the question is you know here
you're showing
that some cryptographic object existing
shows a problem is actually hard
and you get an equivalence you know this
problem is NPR if and only if some
cryptographic object is really
impression yeah I think that's a great
question uh so I I think it might be
some ideas for doing this maybe we could
talk about it offline
yeah I think it's a I think it's
definitely a good question
any other questions
oh yeah that's a good point and so n
here is going to be like the length of X
and oh sorry theorem two and here is
going to be like some polynomial or I
guess it's the length of X and then Y is
some poly and so with equal to a little
bit yeah yeah that's true and here is
going to be a x is a truth table Y is a
truth table and I should say in this
setting we're back into the sublinear
equation because this is and this is an
unconditional results maybe you wouldn't
expect it
when did we start how much time do I
have
it's uh the query will be Oracle
Aquarius 20 20 minutes yeah so what uh
just in the definition of CC of x given
y yes how's what's the excess of why in
that model the access is that you get a
gate in your circuit and uh you know you
uh that gate is going to compute what
functions described by y does that
answer the question
just following up on the potential
equivalence questions so the ideal model
that you're using is a real greatest
encoding what is the yeah so the
potential equivalence is between a
conditional witness encryption
encoding and MP harvesting I see I I
don't know if that was the original
question that's like I think maybe the
original question was like without the
ideal world but still with the idea okay
let's uh let's talk about it later
uh yeah I I think
yeah that seems reasonable
[Music]
first theorem 2 what should I think the
length of Y is being
some polynomial then so X is of length m
y is going to be a blank polynomial
s
uh it's because like if the circuit has
only uh is has complexity n to the 0.49
that means you only made n to the 0.49
queries to y
EP uh and so if Y is of length let's say
n to the 100 it's uh sublinear number of
you've only read a sublinear number of
bits
yeah but this will work also for larger
and larger so
there's the restrictions that you made
by somebody you know that the circuit
always work is sublinear time the input
lens okay so it's sublinear in the sense
that you've only queried a sublinear
portion of Y that's awesome
it's not like something
okay cool let me so now let me tell you
what what this encryption is
uh because I haven't said that yet and
you know hopefully this is this is a
really cool object so as far as I know
I'm not a cryptographer but as far as I
know it was first proposed in this paper
uh
and uh roughly what witness encryption
enables you to do is is something along
the lines of the statement
suppose you have some message M and you
only want
to be able to send that message M to
people who have a proof that P is not
equal to NP you know
um in fact actually you
you know I'm lying a little bit you
really need a short proof that P is not
equal then people could let's forget
about that so suppose you want to do
that
witness encryption is some object that
lets you do this in particular the setup
is as follows
you're given some formula fee and some
message M so this is some stat formula
feed and you can map it to some
encrypted message this is like the lock
box based on on fee
and you have the following guarantee
if someone happened to have a witness
that fee is satisfiable then there are
some polynomial time decryption
procedure which takes this encryption
and spits up a message
and uh
the other uh condition you have is that
if he happens to be unsatisfiable
then this encryption you know this I'm
lying here a bit but let's just pretend
it's pseudo-random against adversaries
running in a lot of time and actually a
couple things I want to mention here
well first first let's uh forget about
this running time part because that's
really just a sub exponential security
uh there there's actually a gap here in
terms of
well ideally what you'd want is you'd
want to say only people with a witness
can decrypt this is not saying that it's
saying if you had a witness you can
decrypt if it happens to be
unsatisfiable then you learn nothing it
doesn't say like if it is satisfiable
and you don't know a witness doesn't say
anything about that that's some
cryptographic technicality it's uh
it's a strong emotion called destructive
extractable yeah but I guess this is
unclear whether it exists or not right
yeah there's a stronger notion of
extractable witness encryption which
would give you this but uh you know
let's not talk that's all you need but
this is all you this is all we need yeah
yeah this is all we need and uh so one
thing that's really cool about the
subscription scheme and this is
something that we're going to use is is
this encryption screen is going to look
pseudo-random even to adversaries
running in 2 to the m to the 100th time
and you might think well that's
impossible like the message is only of
length M how could you be secure against
adversaries running in two to the end of
the 100th time
yeah exactly
no but the point is this encryption is
going to be of length much larger than M
so now now you're seeing okay so this
this is something that I'm going to come
back to late that will be used later
that like the running time here actually
that you're secure against is massive uh
so if you're confused by that you should
ask a question now how does the length
of M relate to the length of the formula
let's say the length of the message is
some polynomial and the size of feet but
yeah you can State this without with
what you do is you say you can encrypt a
bit and then once you can print a bit
there's the natural way to concatenate
so
yes
right because you don't know I don't
know if p and naught is not equal to ndu
right but I want to let's say I want to
send a message to someone
if it were if they could prove it uh
then they can decrypt the message I'm
using a formula that I don't know
exactly I don't again that's key Point
here I'm not going to know whether it's
satisfied
I mean you could be a fixed thing like
it could be some satisfying it could be
corresponding to whether it's input is a
proof that b is not
like or but yeah
uh yes I mean this is for arbitrary fee
it's some procedure that takes
uh is that answer your question
oh oh it's for any formula it's this
will work for any formula in our
reduction we'll choose form specific
formulas but uh
yes Mike
so I
I probably think he said that only
someone with a proof is P95
there's some Gap here actually this is
the comments about extractable witness
encryption or not yeah that because this
actually doesn't give any guarantee if
this so happens that there was a proof
that P naught equal to NP but you don't
have it with this which I think is your
question okay an answer your question is
no
the answers know that you're not going
to show us yeah
okay any more questions this is great
but you are saying that if it wasn't it
wasn't bad
yeah but I haven't told you what
extractable question is
okay let's not get to I kind of shut up
in this again uh
so let me tell you how to prove actually
does anybody here
this reduction is going to be like two
lines does anybody here see how you
prove that this is NP hard if you had
witness encryption a couple of you I've
told this to already so don't raise your
hand uh but anybody uh you have Ian no
well okay you're trying to break sad or
something so you get a formula and you
don't know if it's satisfiable or not
right so just do witness okay but then
what's your instance X for y
okay
exactly okay uh okay wait wait wait wait
what did you say say it again the the
condition is your message and uh and the
employees
okay I think uh yeah yeah I think you're
saying uh
okay sorry
yeah
that is your message yeah and why is the
encryption using exactly
this object is really syntactically you
know just almost designed to show that
conditional time value I think this is
what you're trying to say
the instance you map it to is just pick
a uniformly random message that's
sufficiently long generates its
encryption and then just consider
message uh encryption here
and now what's the point
well if he happens to be satisfiable
then okay what's a really nice way to
describe M you just hard code in
the satisfying assignment and then run
decryption on the conditional string you
have access to the conditional string
just do it
and the the witness here is only of
length n so you'll get this I'm hiding
some fat other things here
on the other hand
if p is unsatisfiable then the security
guarantee of this encryption is so
strong
uh that actually like this The Brute
Force algorithm for like uh checking
it's uh uh yes
isn't the encryption function going to
be randomized though yeah the encryption
oh yeah sorry this is a randomized
reduction okay no but
what I'm worried about is uh
okay is the decrypted also randomized oh
okay the encryption is basically yeah
okay
yeah
oh sorry but even if it was randomized
that's fine oh I see
okay but decryption is not randomized oh
okay yeah but that's important I guess
yeah it just passed away
okay yeah we're just worried that it's a
little larger than m
INE so um
right so if he is unsatisfiable then the
security of this is so long it is
against adversaries that run in so much
time that it actually is against
adversaries that run in time like way
more than the Brute Force algebra
request
and uh you know if that made sense to
you great if that doesn't make sense to
you uh the srem is the security because
uh against randomized uh protocols as
well like can you show
oh I see yeah yeah you can show that
okay
but the encryption is so strong that
actually this thing is going to have to
basically require maximum
does it make sense at least does the
intuition that these two objects are
kind of like you know you squint that
one and you get the other black box
reduction together that's what I want to
convey to you
okay so now how do you prove theorem too
this is unconditional
well this original paper of garg's
gentry so high in waters you know these
guys are as far as I understand real
cryptographers you know they wouldn't
let love crypto I don't think they
really I don't know if they really care
about that I can fix it but what they
did I didn't realize it is uh
or maybe they didn't realize I don't
know uh they actually showed this you
know really uh so they gave this
candidate witness encryption scheme
based on multi-linear maps you know you
know they didn't State this in the paper
but you can show that this scheme is
secure and some generic Oracle model and
uh
where you had like an ideal multi-linear
map so now what do you think what are
you gonna do to show the stuff you just
you take this model and you put it into
the string line
um and then you just run the reduction
as before so it literally actually these
Security in these ideal worlds
um unconditionally show this complexity
applications that doesn't make sense or
at least yeah it's well I think what's
really cool here is that like you know
once you know the Middle East objects
it's actually like the jump from the
crypto provincess results is not really
that hard it's uh really just a matter
of person Yeah just something okay I
don't understand photography at all but
there's something interesting happened
with
um randomized versions
trademark
s into into the conditions string
because as far as I know there's a bunch
of random Oracle results in the crypto
section right and
is there a natural way to line that up
with it just like yeah that's a yeah
that's a good question
um I don't think
this is the Oracle construction is a
random Oracle because
you know yeah would allow you to do
Secret agreement for example right right
um yeah it's a good question let's uh
all right uh so some things how much
time do I have
five minutes okay cool so well let me
highlight a few things that are kind of
interesting about this and these are
things that I think you know we as
authors don't yet understand yes
um one cool thing about here is that
here you get pretty good hardness
approximation which is strange because
usually when you get hardness of
approximation there's a PCP in there
somewhere and here is you know we're not
really using pcps I mean we're using
this ggsw scheme but uh is there some
PCP hiding in here or is there something
special about this problem that lets you
get uh this hardness approximation I
don't know this is it seems like an
interesting question
another
interesting uh aspect is this notion of
secret sharing schemes I mentioned
earlier that hirohara has this result
which you know is for a related
conditional problem that doesn't quite
get uh this level of hardness or
approximation gets this n to the one
over log log n
and that's based on information
theoretic secret sharing and somehow so
you can show that uh witness encryption
is basically is it equivalent or or it
implies equivalent to computational
secret sharing so what's going on here
you have one result
I see uh
so we have one result which is using
information theoretic secret sharing and
it uh you know gives you some hardness
results you have another result showing
computational Secrets which is basically
assuming computate or using
computational sharing it's giving you
another result I know some something
interesting is probably Happening Here
and uh yes I think one thing that's cool
that actually this is these two are
things that we don't understand this one
I guess we kind of understand but it's
kind of interesting that security in
cryptography you know you have these
ideal models and sometimes it's not
always clear what the takeaway is but
actually Security in these ideal models
at least in this setting is giving you
like rigorous applications consequences
and complexity Theory which is kind of
fun
all right
so
I probably have like three minutes now
right
so I'm gonna really quickly
no I'm not you can Define mcsp on
relations there's some way to do it
let's not worry about it you could but
you could Define mcsp and relations
and um
it turns out that you know we actually
already know this problem is and be hard
based on some of shuichi's work
but
um if you want to get better hardness of
approximation
you can get better hardness
approximation using snarks now what is a
snark
well okay I'm not gonna sorry uh if you
had snogs you can get better hardness
approximation that leads to some theorem
I'm not gonna let's not talk about the
theorem yet I don't want to convey the
idea to you which is that snogs are
somehow related to some version of
mcsparks in the plane model right you
cannot rely on there yeah yeah so
exactly but then yeah yeah
okay so if you had snarks in the plane
model uh
snargasm cryptographic object
oh right there's a whole joke here about
some I was gonna be like oh you need
some very smart prover over here and
then you need some kind of dinky
verifier over here
um okay but I will ask it that joke it's
like uh okay all right
um
yeah okay you can read the paper all
right but there's
but uh just like the other other
reduction was like uh one line and it
turns out that the reduction between
this is also one line so there's
basically what you do is you don't
Define a relation that is uh consists of
the truth table of the verifier run on a
random string and Pi with P hard coded
in if you know what that means uh and
the reduction you know almost basically
goes through if you have some
exponential security
um so just to recap here are some
examples where you have this two sides
of the coin where there's some
cryptographic object and its existence
is implying black box and the hardness
of meta complexity you have these
examples with this encryption and snugs
uh you know so uh thanks for listening
to this talk and
so I have a question so where is the
loss in your behind this for uh in CSP
like a conditional Code table because uh
yeah let me just go back to the theorem
statement so it's clear that I really
wasn't
um
so you know ideally what you would like
to show is that this is n and that's uh
or maybe n to the 0.99 and that's into
the point zero one and there is some
loss coming from some technical factor
that we we actually think we're hoping
to remove before okay
actually oh that's a good point if any
of you are interested in the paper just
send us an email it's not online yet but
we're happy to send you a draft uh it
should come online
[Music]
but that's we need to do something
makeup yeah yeah it's like yeah
same some like some technicality it's
probably fruitable
again
thank you